[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous alors je ne chante pas je
fais pas de piano maintenant vous fermez
les yeux fermés les yeux
imaginez-vous en 1981 et vous entendez
les tubes du top 50 à la radio toto
téléphone toutes ces musiques vous les
entendez et vous regarder la télévision
et à ce moment là vous voyez ces images
des premiers rallyes raids en afrique
le paris dakar le paris-dakar ces images
qui me font rêver ses pilotes autos
motos qui tentent l'impossible et ces
motards amateurs qui vont jusqu'au bout
de leur vie qui vont jusqu'à eux jusqu'à
aller au bout d'eux mêmes
oui ces gens ma pression je veux être
cyril neveu ou hubert auriol à 15 ans en
1981 à 15 ans je décide de quitter
l'école et de choisir une voie
professionnelle d'être dessinateur en
construction métallique dans
l'entreprise de mon papa pourquoi
dessinateur parce que j'étais j'ai été
toujours un crayon à la main et je
voyais toujours cette planche à dessin
dans la cuisine de mes parents et là
j'ai toujours cette passion pour la moto
et avec mes premiers salaires je me paye
ma première mobylette d'occasions un
bijou de mécanique une peugeot 103
et cette mobylette
je la bichonne jeu la transforme jeu-là
trafic et pour faire quoi
des courses de mobylette sur les
parkings de supermarché mais pour moi
les parkings de supermarché
c'était comme le champion du monde qui
va rouler sur le circuit du mans ou du
castellet et je rêve et je rêve et à
l'âge de 17 ans ces courses de moto me
passionne de plus en plus j'obtiens mon
crp de dessinateur en construction
métallique
nous sommes en 1984 et là je me pose la
question est ce que j'ai choisi ce
métier par passion ou est ce que j'ai
voulu par facilité suivre le sillon que
mon père avait tracé et à ce moment là
j'ai eu une révélation je me dis mais ça
fait trois ans que je côtoie un
passionné d'informatique l'informatique
métiers d'avenir et je décide de quitter
l'entreprise familiale de masquer en
cours du soir et de fer programmeurs
programmeurs oui en cours du soir il
fallait travailler et donc j'ai choisi
de travailler comme ouvrier dans une
entreprise américaine en équipe 3 x 8
passionnant le travail mais par contre
j'avais toujours mes cours mes cours mes
cours et le travail et je fais mes cours
et que je continue la moto et tout ça je
cours après le temps sans jamais le
rattraper un jour je passe mon permis
moto et me voilà qui tombe sur une revue
spécialisée dans le tout-terrain moi qui
faisais du tout terrain pour les loisirs
voilà que je vois dans ce magazine
un encart qui propose d'emmener les
jeunes de moins de 25 ans traverser le
désert le sahara algérien
magique je répond immédiatement à
l'annonce je suis
ex thione et là je prends conscience que
je peux vivre mon rêve que j'ai
l'opportunité et la chance d'aller en
algérie faire un rallye mais pour mettre
toutes les chances de mon côté
à ce moment là je décide de prendre
toutes mes économies et je vais chez le
concessionnaire acheter une moto tout
terrain tout neuf est pareil cette moto
je la prépare je la transforme je la
bichonne jour après jour et puis après
de longs mois d'attentes ce jour arrive
le départ je suis excité je prends la
route pour le port de marseille arrivé
sur le vieux port
je vois les autres concurrents les motos
les véhicules d'assistance
l'organisation mais me voilà dans cette
ambiance de rallye voilà je suis pilote
de rallye moi qui n'ai jamais voyager
ailleurs qu'en france
moi qui n'ai jamais traversé la mer
voilà que je vais traverser la
méditerranée pour rejoindre l'afrique et
réaliser mon rêve je savoure tous ces
moments ces rencontres et après être
arrivée sur le port d'alger après des
attentes interminables de contrôle
douanier voilà que les militaires nous
escortent jusqu'au début de la course et
là je roule heureux sur ma moto je
traverse les villages et les villes en
convoi et je vois tous ces spectateurs
qui nous applaudissent et qui sont là
pour nous et là je me rends compte que
je suis ce pilote de rallye les
l'illusion d'être connus et reconnus
comme pilote de rallye
à ce moment là les jours passent le
quatrième jour arrive le quatrième jour
l'entrée du désert le désert le désert
le sable à perte de vue les dunes mais
aussi le silence
pas de trace de vie humaine et ce désert
qui me rappelle ces images du paris
dakar que je regardais sans arrêt et je
me rappelle de ces motards qui
traversait ses grandes étendues
désertiques seul et me voilà en train de
vivre cette aventure mois jean-philippe
je vis cette aventure de motards dans le
désert et je suis content heureux de
vivre ces moments là le briefing du
lendemain comme chaque jour nous annonce
les difficultés du jour et ce jour avait
une atmosphère particulière parce qu'on
nous annonce quelque chose de dangereux
de deux difficile avec beaucoup de
kilomètres à parcourir sur des pistes du
paris dakar
mais moi j'entends paris dakar et voilà
on me dit il faut prendre la route des
pistes du paris dakar
quel rêve le rêve se réalise et malgré
toutes ces difficultés
la nuit tombe le sable des autres
concurrents les poussières des véhicules
d'assistance
je continue à rouler moi content fier
virevoltant sur ma moto et je roule je
pilote comme un pilote de motocross
j'évite les bosses et voilà je me sens
invincible
j'ai la sensation d'être seul au monde
et que rien ne m'arrêtera tout d'un coup
une bosse et je m'envole au dessus du
sable je plonge dans une cuvette
profonde rempli d'un sable aussi fin que
la farine
ma moto est bloqué jusqu'à la moitié des
roues
et là je percute avec le casque
réservoir de ma moto je suis sonné je ne
comprends pas ce qui m'arrive je suis
lourd le temps s'arrête
les secondes s'égrènent mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est une éternité
et me voilà bloqués au fond de ce trou
je prends conscience peu à peu qu'il
faut sortir de ce trou et à ce moment-là
je me dis prends tes forces et redémarre
cette moto et je redémarre plusieurs
fois cette moto qui ne veut pas démarrer
qui est bloqué dans ce sable et à ce
moment-là je me dis le rêve que je
touchais du bout des doigts s'envole je
suis épuisé à bout de forces
je suis là j'abandonne j'attends les
secours au fond de ce trou mais tout
d'un coup il me vient à l'esprit que
j'ai doublé à grand nombre de véhicules
d'autres concurrents et ses camions et
ses voitures qui vont venir derrière moi
plongée de nuit dans cette cuvette et
m'écraser et là comme un mauvais film ma
vie défile et je me dis mais qu'est ce
que je vais laisser comme trace mais est
ce que j'ai vécu la vie que j'ai
réellement voulu et à ce moment là je
suis là je prend peu à peu conscience
que je dois me sortir de cette situation
je dois sortir parce que ma vie tout
entière n'avait aucune valeur et que
j'ai rien fait dans ma vie j'ai pas
trouvé ma voie j'ai pas trouvé mon
métier et cette énergie je la trouve je
dégage ma moto avec mes mains je dégage
ma moto je la pousse de toutes mes
forces même si elles me semblent peser
des tonnes et je la dégage et je repars
j'arrive à repartir puis j'entends les
moteurs des autres concurrents qui
arrive derrière moi et là je prends
conscience à nouveau
je vient d'échapper au pire à ce moment
là je roule de nuit sur ces pistes de
motocross et je tombe et je me relève et
je tombe et je me relève plusieurs
dizaines de fois et là je vois la
lumière du camp l'arrivée je suis sauvé
je dépose mon carnet aux contrôles de
passage je m'effondre de la moto à bout
de force les organisateurs et les
médecins m'emmène à l'infirmerie et à ce
moment là moi j'ai qu'une idée en tête
reprendre ma moto ma moto je dois faire
mon assistance de départ est dans moins
de trois heures il faut que je sois prêt
je n'abandonnerai jamais ce rallye est
là le lendemain le jour n'est pas encore
levé et je prends conscience que je
viens de changer le cours de ma vie
cette vie ne sera plus comme avant
je dois changer ma vie je dois trouver
ce que j'ai envie rencontrer des gens
plus riche intense en échange
voilà ce que je veux changer ma vie je
finis le rallye je suis pas j'ai pas été
premier j'ai pas gagné mais je suis allé
au bout de moi même j'ai fini le rallye
j'ai réussi ce rêve qui m'a donné une
confiance en moi j'ai quitté
l'entreprise
j'ai recherché un métier où je pouvais
nouveau exercer mon premier métier de
dessinateur et j'ai choisi de reprendre
les études
et à ce moment là je m'inscris au
conservatoire national des arts et
métiers le cnam une épreuve aussi le
cnam ce que vous savez quand vous
rentrez mais vous savez pas quand vous
sortez
j'ai fait ça pendant quatre ans quatre
ans où je travaille et j'étudie mais je
n'oublie jamais ma passion et je prépare
déjà le prochain rallye du maroc
je fais ça pendant quatre ans jusqu'à
obtenir mon sésame pour entrer à l'iut
de strasbourg faire un dut de génie
civil mois qui avec un ca paix à
l'origine
et voilà que j'obtiens ce dut et là je
me dis mais la voie que j'ai choisie se
trace peu à peu ce chemin se dessine
devant moi et je choisis un nouveau défi
parce que je suis un homme de défi et ce
défi là je veux devenir ingénieur et je
choisis une voix quelle alternance la
théorie et la pratique dans des
entreprises différentes dans des métiers
différents et avec des hommes différents
j'obtiens ce diplôme d'ingénieur dix ans
après mon changement de vie j'exerce
pendant deux ans dans une entreprise de
charpente de bois les deux ans plus tard
je décide de racheter le bureau d'études
de mon père de le développer vers
d'autres activités mais surtout d'oser
aussi déplacé les limites de nos savoir
faire ce que j'ai retenu de cette
aventure exceptionnelle cette aventure
qui m'a transformé
c'est que si chacun de nous on prend
conscience qu'on est capable de changer
sa vie j'ai compris des choses qui
paraissent banales mais je me suis dit
finalement j'ai eu la chance de vivre
dans un pays où on allait dos des
libertés j'ai la chance d'avoir une
famille qui m'a donné du bonheur et moi
qui aurait pu être dans un événement
tragique
voilà que je suis devenu acteur de ma
vie voilà que j'ai changé le cours de ma
vie
oui cette révélation m'a donné le
courage et l'énergie pour devenir ce que
je suis aujourd'hui
s je ne sais pas si vous connaissez
cette phrase de confucius qui dit on a
deux vies la deuxième commence quand on
se rend compte qu'on en a qu'une seule
et si votre vie s'arrêtait ce soir est
votre deuxième vie commence et demain
quelles limites allez vous déplacer
merci beaucoup mais revault